there are only very few people in
germany who have managed to do this in recent years and
decades and also
wanted to and to build a company
empire with their surname and their
first name also bears the expensive
swiss one of them has now managed to
become very rich as it is
run  if the money paid for the
company and how many rooms
earned between average
why there is a lever there means vouchers that have not been
redeemed all that this
trip of the former stood if it is now
to the million dollar west there is
now hello my husband can already
say  you've lived a pretty incredible life
so far, so from somehow
there were more jobs to
big company tv jobs
now also to the bestselling author what
was your life not talking about far away
i think there's still a lot but
i didn't let too much burn
as it went  it's going on so you have
an unusual way gene  hen the
entrepreneurial world
could start i think i would say so you will
go through from logistician to stuntman or from stand to logistician and then to entrepreneur i just always
did it i always took advantage of the
opportunities that were offered to me
and things are simple  done that means
if you're like that then understand
and then it was a logistician that means
you somehow drove trucks around the area
for money there's the
story that you were even then
somehow looking
for missing trucks in Africa  and on the other hand
, let's say you've taken unusual paths
, well, that's
different, but after graduating
from high school, I drove through Africa in a motorized vehicle.
Of course, I learned a lot on this trip,
experienced a lot, and then I was attacked in Lomé in Togo
I got a
swiss
CEO of a big
logistic organization out of
trouble  n
under the condition that I
do a job for him while I was still
on the road with my motorcycle, namely
to accompany a truck convoy to Bamako Mali
and
to write and photograph a documentary about it
that he actually
only did it so as not to give me the feeling
that  he finally got me something to
work for that was a great privilege and
this
chairman of the board of directors of this forwarding organization unfortunately his name rudolf
niehaus is long dead he
then called me at some point when
i was a student and said listen
, somehow 40 trucks went missing
you can fly the upper volta to baku and see
what's going on there again okay kohl
that really looks like wacker thun look
what's going on
there they fit we can now
found them so the load was of
course gone but the trucks I
found and have  then hired drivers
and, in an unusual
way, got them to their destination in bamako in mali
brought you have to be very creative
with regard to the documents you create
and the limits that have to be overcome
it worked and then i delivered it
to the german embassy in bamako in
mali and then later became a
logistician in this same
organization okay okay
and then in addition to your time as a
logistician you already started as a
stuntman and making things, so to speak,
action sports, so to speak, also
making films yourself that was then
your time is up then yes,
yes, I always did something because
I always understood myself as an entrepreneur
as an entrepreneur in my own
life, i don't have it in the economic sense at all,
but
if you understand that you have this
gift, that this life
and if you want to make the most of
all the opportunities that are available,
then you have to do something
and
tell us what you have. then there are any
highlights  the early days but
what was for japan is not mine
stuntman we had his hours
but that was what
led to that then afterwards
the famous experience
voucher was that it
started like
that you had experiences yourself or created them on a
small scale without building a platform
for but  that's funny about it
, isn't
it, so you're asking me how i
then went from being an entrepreneur to the
economic situation,
you can say yes
, that happened by mistake, i
was involved in a film with willy
bogner with roger moore in the leading role
and
uwe ochsenknecht journey dynamite as a stuntman is known
as legendary and now
children are shooting stories or do you see me
in many roles in this film and
among other things we drove there very extremely
nobody and there is a
gorge in valle verzasca with a
waterfall that was previously unknown  so
really at real this part
and we had a long break from
shooting  d some people who know the fourth
quarter also know this old
genoese bridge that goes 20 meters high
over this gorge deep water and
back down and there we have as
nonsense from these expander rubbers with
which the kayaks
were fixed on the transport vehicles so
our district  we
made some nonsense out of these expander rubbers
and jumped off this bridge
during the break in shooting because it was boring
okay and
and does he really come by
and he said to me what's wrong with my
yokes you can jump off the
dam wall with it and I like that  according to
lovely
[laughter]
what i didn't know was this penalty was
220 meters deep ok ok and two
days later i jumped this dam wall with a
rubber rope I made myself
and that was then
there i suddenly became
a different person so that was
somehow actually should have been  since everyone can
jump you could have
talked too of course you need
a bit  en nail in my head and doing something like that
but physically it was
n't the big challenge at all, except
that maybe during the test throw the barrel
that I had closed down smashed in the
dam wall because the congas
is and I solved the problem
by hanging it up
I moved the point 30 meters outside via an autograph
and then the
rope centered me, so to speak, so that in these
recordings, which were then
repeated with James Bond Goldeneye,
you were very close along the wall, so to speak,
but why not pulled by magical hands
collides with the wall
but falls down along this wall
in mainz 200 meters is
quite high
right there the film was finished and was
promoted in 60 countries around the
world bought by disney then they
suddenly lifted me up for
something
which I personally didn't find that
unusual, namely you just add
this tax to it  jumping
and lust there I was two and with that I
jumped the deep so that's exactly
that I was suddenly kind of the industry
guru and they carried me around on the sign
but actually I'm
kaká and I can do other things much better
and that's where this whole
bungie came from  movement and three years
later i had 40 bungee jump systems
all over europe and sold 60,000 jumps
and that was the start, so to speak, the experience vouchers, so to speak,
because that was
the core result with which everything
started and you thought about it over the years
okay i can't
experience them all myself
so i have to say
we have to go back in the value chain
and are now looking for other providers who also
offer cool things and collect them on
a platform yes exactly when do we
start everything friends i had a
buddy who  had an ice peter
firner the next one had a nonsense a
third one had a flight  school because
I was also a passionate flyer
at the time I always had a paradox: I was
always parachuting and so
I actually made experiences out of my own
experience horizon
and made them tradable in the
form of experience boxes and vouchers
and I initially operated this business model
analogously  by hand,
so to speak, mirka luft simply listens analogously, i.e.
you put these
boxes together and
sold
food retail or or
where did you sell them through all
sorts of sales or areas,
including through thalia, for example, a
book
and in
2004 facebook was founded and until you
classify  In 2002 you can say that
the digital
age began. I had been there for ten years and I was
selling experience gift boxes, but they were experience
gift boxes, they were as big as
shoe boxes and there was the
ultimate experience and there were just
different  e cool stuff in it and a
voucher for it
and I'll band jukebox was
then there were pieces of bungee cord in it and
areas of the little cowards and measure the
parachute jump was then there was a
pin inside the so the identification mark of
the wrong jumper it's such a
curved one  metal part with which the reserve is
fixed in the container and it
carries the wrong response and
recognition symbol
and and in 2004 i digitized the topic
and that was
before that i sold 10,000 or 20,000
such experience boxes a year
and when i  then digitized and
built my first website that
was pretty much the same in 2004 yes when
facebook was founded then the
business model
literally exploded and
not long after that we sold a million boxes a year
what was but the value
but box so if the
what has to be protected was bought we
actually made 100 million in sales
dam  it okay it says somehow it costs 100 euros
without boxes as an average
awakening comes and you
could also choose there of course there was
a larger voucher for a smaller or
larger year of life that gives
different experiences and you
can then choose them but they are also
exchangeable a lot  other
so it's well known i think there is no one
who listens to her isn't that hasn't
seen it before yeah sure and tell me
what was like with these one million
different options what was that the
hit so you're one when it's in
continue the bungee jumping offers
or goods is what was the
product what made it great when
i look back at the beginning little
allowed said 100 different
experiences and nothing more and
whenever something new comes along then something
old kicks out that was the basic idea because
i  I thought that would be the most successful
approach, then I
found out it's worth doing a
experience which is then only
bought once a year
to make one understand because responding to such an experience has to
be put online
causes opportunity costs and
you now have that once yes let’s say
such an experience and reports have
real costs of  two to three thousand
euros and once you have
answered it, it doesn't really make any sense
to take it down because from that point on it doesn't cost
anything on the
portal and that has led
to more and more experiences
becoming well over 3,000 to date  and
then of course there are the top 30,
with which we still make
70 to 80 percent of our sales
, but in the search
engine many other experiences are searched for
and they are all there and the customer
often buys what is obvious and
obvious  it's just a candle light
dinner, for example, or a
parachute jump, those are the
top products if I add the two
categories adr  enalin and endorphin or
enjoy
and what many didn't
understand the competitor and that's why
we became the market leader
against really strong competition, among other things, was
that you also need signature products, i.e.
these very authentic, honest
things that are completely worn by the brennt
and there  for example, i have the
absolute soul product at the start with me
even at home in my brand house in
the jochen schweizer arena, namely
surfing on a real deep
water pressure wave that is really
comparable to the eisbach in munich
and the institute products with which you
might not  makes a lot of money and
maybe can’t display such high frequencies at all
, but it
brings an incredible amount of spirit to the
brand, i mean all these questions that
you probably ask yourself
conversion how do you get the best
events to convert what do you need,
so to speak, which events do  in the
ha  ndel to draw people in who
are bought later all these questions in the
trade were foreign words for some times i
only found out in the last two three
years what that means now
the young boy i am not a driver but
i mean that means you can get yourself
a little bit  imagine how it
came about you just did
about what you already said and then noticed
you are doing something about it but didn't you do
that now through optimized me
would do it today exactly like
your name so that was always
jochen schweizer you  yes also
obviously
not really anymore and in
germany it weighed naming companies after themselves
with what we were different
i never thought about it i
mean i had become very well known as a stuntman
i set a few world records
and and was just well known yes  and i
thought to myself if i do it for skiing
it won't take long, so
everyone will copy me  I
thought to myself, I'll do jochen schweizer bungie,
then people will know that there's someone
behind you who is serious and
who does his best, but
nevertheless it went a long way in the end
, when was the point where you
got the first  really
economically i thought okay i
've gotten rich with all these activities
what you would say colloquially
my grandmother always said to me
boy always try to take in a market
more than the target spends then
you'll never have any problems
i've gotten myself up to  held up today but is
that it works really great i
mean in the times when it made 100 million
sales and the company was
more or less owned by itself at that time it
wasn’t that you were
there then that one
was already there at the beginning so i had  so at the
beginning only when i came up with the
idea and then
really needed a lot of money for the digitization
because things just weren't going that well  n as they
say today, cleaned rap would have worked
because i was still on the trip
i now have to position
ten different experience
boxes molar teeth at 10,000 sales outlets in germany in a
merchandise management system
you need three
million for the packaging alone, yes, and
i had the money  yes not and
then i went out and looked for
investors in the end found
them but after three years I was able to
buy them out of the company again they have everything
very good so yes they all got money several
times the investors but of course i also wanted to
be the sole owner of the
company  again i
managed that so it was very lucrative
years for you you can
easily imagine the beautiful model is
the people pay in advance in which you
would buy the voucher you
somehow only have to pay for it later so the
event what what you  since sale then
you don't have to
pay immediately and it  there's this famous
great kitzscher that's what it's called i think
that means a lot of vouchers are
never redeemed when they
're paid for by you but then you never have to pay has
a no a yes a voucher
service provider or because
the customer who showed up
is that  a whole pack
well that's all right what you say
you have a linear is difference
between buying and selling an
experience from an external experience
partner and then you have the so called
no show rate there is a percentage
of gutscheine.de to a
solution it  there is a big one
but a competitor has also
done it wrong they have always tried
to optimize the ticket quota i have always
tried the opposite i have always
tried to ensure that
as many vouchers as possible are redeemed and
that was my thought based on a very simple ratio
in the long term it is good if the
vouchers are redeemed because j  a
each redemption if you hate a good
system and the experiences are cabbage is
currently faction leads to the
one who redeems the voucher and
redeems the voucher, it is very often
they who have not bought the
voucher because the largest part is just
sold is just given away  but
at the end of the day there is a no
show quote left over and that of course
also contributes to the company’s profitability of
roughly the order of magnitude that
’s something we don’t publish
so nobody in the industry
is that far that of course so I
had the one that was asked  others not
okay well then that would be
so if you don't know then
they probably would they would
tell me so I once heard but
without knowing it that now douglas
if douglas bought
vouchers for douglas products that means that
these vouchers are now in  the
box quota would have been 20 percent,
you're okay, I
'm afraid of that too h  but i didn't say
but should be okay so even they have
20 percent i heard the no
stock where it's not good for the
business model and it's also not
good for those who buy the vouchers
is also not good for the company
and
generally in the  over the whole year you built
up 100 million companies but
had more than 500 people then later owned this
company alone that's
an amazing entrepreneurial achievement
was there someone who didn't
support me or so I mean
it's not natural that someone
can build something up
i.e. independently taking a company boots or investor back to the size
how was it possible to succeed when you the
model is open super strong the
name as a brand worked great
but what was there as a guest
you have to know other things that
contributed to the fact that you
my co-workers could get that big so I had I
have I have maybe there  s had a real hand
but
i am
myself i am actually a pretty normal
guy dont like to do things like go to the
mountains kayaking i like being
outside
i hate sitting at a desk
this is not my forte and i have
always tried to be people i am  also
not particularly smart when it comes to digital
systems i always knew
this and never overestimated myself
and was always looking for people in
the areas that i knew
would be terribly
important i looked for them and found them
who hears me talk regularly here
knows how important software selection is
sometimes however needs more than
a platform in itself needs a
whole team so real people
we have to help software selection and
implementation and that
could be for example was state parliament
warns with mrs and you end up because
antic supported by  the strategy through
the organization to the final
implementation imme  r then when
customer engagement turns to technologies
so the focus is somehow on the customer
, then valentin comes along, be it
customer data, be it experience,
platform, be it customer feedback,
customer loyalty or holistic,
so if a customer turns, then it
was antic linking marketing from
sales and service all that goes through
vallant x6 you're in the right place there and
would like to get to know
her colleagues, of course she'd also be present at the festival 17 and 18 times, of
course,
but it was then with you that
you always made the decision despite the
attractive company say  what would it be then
maybe that once understand the attractiveness in
addition to the
voucher that was not redeemed, there was simply a normal
margin as is because this was so
shopping sales pitch is it like with
e-commerce in the clothing area or how
do you imagine
that so the experience partners give  between
15 and 25 percent of
their margin eased up to the
marketing costs was the very first market
so jochen schweizer was first no
ok that means it was the idea was
n't invented by you at all
and they already existed both are correct
i actually invented the
experience gift box from ten years
ago in england better days with  an
experience gift box came out these were
the first testers had systematized the
data we had long since our bungie box with
a voucher redeemable at all bands
stations house running was added these
were these shoe boxes as i
would call them today i
had done that ten years earlier so
if  you want to know so if i
maybe will but not important i
could claim it for myself
i invented the experience gift
box but it didn't really matter england did it quite well
later went bankrupt and in
germany there were
I've been to a lot of golden moments mydays that were forgotten again e  s
definitely 12 14 competitors
and mydays actually prevailed among
these among these competitors
but in the end
jochen schweizer was better
i say that today with a smile
because i am involved in my is
today but mostly it worked out well and they
are very stringent  drove on the
rescue concept and they did
it very, very well but they did
n't make it to market
leadership that's what jochen schweizer succeeded in doing
and because what was decisive, so to speak, in
the end it's the
question that we have the attitude i mean
supermarket they have super products
I also always valued the founder fabrice
schmidt very much, of
course we worked it out on all levels,
so our online
teams shot at each other where
possible and optimized where possible, but
that was somehow a halfway
fair boxing match anyway, I say now  times
this fight both seniors
swiss know but then also all
a  Change all the other external market
that is, by the way, maybe it is
also a market that tends towards a duopoly,
yes, but in the end it is also a marketing
gamer, so you have to have the experiences on
the platform, but that is
probably not the case  it's difficult
that everyone has the cool stuff
because everyone, as you just described
, is also interested when they
offer something great, that people see it again and
again, but the crucial
thing is that you get my new customers
on board, finding new buyers
is mine  in the marketing battle or
that you drove there that made
the difference i think in the
end it made the difference that
we managed to generate generic traffic
and it was quite good that i called that
video or the brand was like that  me,
because I
was mostly done now and
people rightly believe that
and insofar everyone has my medial
appearances be it now as a speaker at
a cinema you know that now what do
i know an insurance and when
you stand on such a stage and then speak on
these topics with honest
conviction then there are just a
bunch of people down there in the
auditorium who  then they say hey cool
, that's somehow true and they end up on
the website
and think it's a good idea
to give away their experience. that's what i call
generic traffic, which was of course driven by my
person
and i was very present
on tv and in different
concepts and that's for sure
contributed to the
fact that we were not forced to
buy the lion's share of the traffic at high prices,
but we were able to
generate this traffic
generically, which means that
you somehow strategically
decided for yourself. I'm going out now
and I'm not going to become a media
person anymore  that's how it
came, so I did
n't even write my first book
I wrote it because I meant I'll write it up
so that more people come to the arena
or go to the website. I wrote the
book because I felt the
need to write a book
and of course I divided it up
afterwards, but in the end he decided at some
point  the company is selling so
we talked about how you set it
up but the
decision was always in favor of sieben sat 1 bought mine
is in the end who bought it too
in 2013 we wanted to buy mydays
and prosiebensat 1 then
usually snatched it from under our noses  does he
also have a tangible reason
we bid five million at the time and
prosiebensat 1 paid 13 because
we were no longer competitive with
our bid and i had more money
and then came the fact that the factory
naturally had to be sold to a competitor
with the  you kind of beat each other for
five years it was kind of
not cool either so i have tota  le
understands his decision and
even if he had
n't sold it to me for the same money i would
have understood it i probably would
n't have sold twice that
to the competitor either but i
would have preferred to have taken two
million from some third party than
from them  a competitor 5 million but
everyone has a different attitude and he did
everything right and sold milesy's to
prosieben and prosieben
then announced we'll do the
schweizer blatt in three years is
n't there anymore that was 13 years ago because we're
pushing now  50 million gross media
tv
on the my days brand and that was the
phase in which the real tv could no
longer be switched on it was
anyway to watch commercials and of course if you are
now a founder entrepreneur
who owns the company alone and has no bank
behind him he  has no investors
behind it and a global corporation is
communicating now we'll flatten you
that has a different quality than if
a global corporation were to say now we're going to
make the second one in the market the
market leader that's a big
difference yes that's normal so there
and then to say I've got 150
million gross media tv in this one
new acquisitions and make the
new acquisition the market leader and replace
the existing market leader
that's what i think it is
, i would have found it to be quite normal,
a normal topic and
the board of directors
at the time hadn't done that at the company for a long time he
just said it like that
what maybe  also expressed an attitude of mind
and then we
just looked at each other in the
company said okay then
at least we know what the
plans are thanks for the information
and now let’s see where Bartl
gets the most
and that has united this company and  the
employees welded together and then
in the end it was so
that we kept getting better and
then e  s in the end so that the group actually made the
idea of the experience gift big for five years with enormous media
& tv power the idea
ut where did the people buy i
and w
bought it from us we gr
w and grew and grew
nd we had  low costs
we were super profitable because they got
simple and generic
traffic and so to
compare it we then switched to
about three million 4 5 million
gross media tv in comparison
we could afford that in the course of our
business plan and the competitors of
then it was bought by the group and the
tv was blown up but in the
end it meant that we became
stronger and stronger
and we focused completely
on the highest quality absolute
credibility
the customer is absolutely in the foreground
but something is still decided
now what to offer  so good that they
made themselves too
overbearing no that was a  nders that was 2016 so it
's that's how it probably came
across it was 2016 i was
in the lion's den three years ago 14 2 15
and 2 16 and i became it 17 60 that
did something to me knew
this birthday was coming
and now i had achieved a lot after all
and was faced with the question of how
to proceed now
and i had a so-called due diligence at pwc in the spring of 2016
so price was
initiated from
cuba and it cost me quite a bit
120,000 euros that that  the mine
companies have
turned upside down on my own behalf to watch
the fact that it has grown so quickly because
everything is in order we have the
right software licenses everywhere the
processes are right i just wanted
i was faced with the decision bring
companies to the stock exchange
and it  Was the original idea or
do I continue to become the status
216 then you can turn the tour
d'elegance out of
the extremely high ratings  and the fact that
we were in pretty good shape there was
n't much that we had to change
to be sparkling clean
and then two 16 came in the fall and at
the same time I had built
the jochen schweizer arena with an investment of 20 million
euros
17 were opened in march 2010 and
we were in the process of completing the jochen
schweizer arena i should have
finished in december and i
wanted
to  lions and it's
so it might look funny from the outside
that jochen is there in
his chair by the fire and so on and
throws out clever sayings but in
reality it's incredibly exhausting when the
lions really do something
and
and it takes a lot of time  claim
because you have to
really take care of these founders if you feel weird about an investment and
at the same time you stand d  u in competition with
the other lions, all alpha animals that's
not like it would be like
to touch his ringelpiez in the cave
and now he has every natural
state creative will that sits there
that wouldn't work there and it
's just exhausting at the beginning they
were  the show's investment case isn't
that exciting just a little bow I
'm in portugal there probably not
necessarily investing
but then suddenly I
saw people but it really works
and this makes a real
contribution to the founding spirit in Germany
and and now it's the second year  although
the year 215 we were all a bit more
professional the format also became more
professional the peaches became more
exciting and then in 216 it
got even better and even more exciting
then things came up too strong guy
really really hard on the wind with everything he
does cool socks  hat is also a
likeable guy he came along and the
format was again i  more interesting and
my workload was in the end as a
tv investor that somehow 70
percent 80 percent of my time i was a
tv investor and now i asked
myself the question so jochen
you did it that you did well
together with sony fox and in
do you want to remain a television investor with lion for the rest of your
life or
do you want to see this as an episode in your
life as a very positive
episode and say i
have other goals now i want to expand the arena
into a conference center but 20
million investment then now
i still need a hotel and a
conference center together with art invest
in the congress center office
complex
investment volume 100 million euros
there we were totally the project starts
next year so the arena will become
a whole district which
will get its own name from the swiss
arena will be part of a large
quarter of an experience quarter with
a hot  el in the office complex
conference center
that was everything, everything just came together
and at the same time i had
this IPO behind me that i
said i will put the thing on the
stock exchange i mean the
adventure portal and then christmas came
and i lapsed i had the first
a crèche
so i'm never sick i was ill for the
first time in 20 years i was
never ill with it 40 fever and got into
a crisis and have but what
are you doing now that
went public and then the  building the
arena and building the district was where are
you actually where are you staying now as a
person as a family man and
then
i thought called the bankers i
think that they got together at a
table saying we are not
going public but let’s do a riddle
and that’s it  Of course they
all had euro signs in their
eyes because they earn a lot of money from such an
IPO and are now reporting on the
alm  the one who can decide all this for
himself we do
n't come up with another idea
yes i say but i'll do it with you i
'll do it with you so i wo
n't click you out with you and then you're allowed to put out a
tender and then came a
stop for the company between stands
yes also everything in
the annual report then from prosieben the bids not but
at least what happened then and has
also been communicated in the media
i can so in that respect it is
not a secret the bids were
between 80 and 150 million euros
only for the digital portal  not
for them i didn't sell the brand i did
n't sell my experience businesses either i
didn't sell my event we're
not sure about selling either and now the arena was
my brand house so i go there every
morning to surf great for you
the company does
[laughter]
and then the
bids came in and then i met thomas ebeling, who was on
the board at the time  chairman who bid a
little over 100 million
and
it wasn't the best bid by far but
i found the guy code who had the
lamp on in his head because he understood
how to get through the one optimizing the
one solutions and winning the
redemption is them  to
convert customers the business model
can be scaled even better instead of always
squinting at the dino show so also
ethically not good to say i do
n't want them to be redeemed i want
the vouchers to be redeemed say
at some point
so watch out thomas
on june 23 i will  60 i made
a decision if we come to the
deal before my sixtieth
birthday then i would be willing to
give the very low
valuation that was offered that was a competition i can
tell you 108 million euros i would be
willing to you singularly in the course of a karting
process  the experience gift portal
for sale yes and then on
june 21 we have two days before the sixtieth
we'll have our birthday at the notary it took 40
hours
it's an absurd process because
only each other read each other's contracts in front
of one insult me in the other frien
s others but it just has to be read
ut you're sleeping ne meet
ou then 20 hours later
who are still reading
it was somehow not
forgotten and then everyone
gathered the entire board everyone it
was also a mega deal and the notary
said to me anyway lothar meyer in
munich
is also daring then last
bavaria says more about that so sir
schweitzer I've already had a few founder
exits from the office
but I've never explored a founder
ex where the founder holds
100 percent of the shares at the time of sale
and not a
single bank is involved, so there's no
outside capital,
that means you  you end up
going home after the notary appointment with
over 100 million in your pocket
next to not quite w
because there are so-called netapps, they are
deducted from the valuation, so the
enterprise value is 108 million
and the net steps are deducted, so
not the net liabilities and
vouchers that have not been redeemed are
net liabilities
and it wasn’t really a secret if anything,
we really didn’t know about it
speaking so openly it was 1 million
97.5 million out and it was the cash
value of the company but that's the same for you but that's what
life changing is for you so having so much money
in your account at once
is not at all  at the same time it's really
shitty
really really i felt awful
afterwards because first of all if
you've been running such successful companies for so
long you've really
earned something and and and and you'll
be fine and your children will be
fine too, so that's not the point
i felt awful
afterwards
for two reasons firstly i would tell anyone
who attended the unt  company has built
and sells it do not recommend selling it as a public
company because then you
do not have to disclose what is really
behind the deal i
can speak freely about it today i went through the
pain because it is
all in the annual report anyway and can be read by
any investigative  journalists
are also being researched, so I won't tell you
any secrets here, secondly, you
pay let's say almost 40
percent of taxes on the exit proceeds,
you're only concerned with this topic, so you
've built up a company, very
simply exchange the balance sheet item
outside the company  times worth
100 million now it's just a smart
tags this value on the same
balance sheet position against cash then
the tax comes first but takes 35
percent of it but that's
why i emigrated to monaco there
are a lot of smarter guys who wanted to say
exit is on is shifted I misplace
my where  domiciled in switzerland and
trading there 15 percent
flat-rate taxation i did
n’t do it i stayed in germany
because i also stand behind germany
and i’m also grateful that this
country and its system
gave me the chance to develop and
i have it  in the end it is so
that you are poorer at first and then they
come to you
that you cannot buy back what you gave away with the money
now you start
to do meaningful things to support founders
also to donate something
i don’t have any  afforded luxury or
something because what i wanted was a
nice house and the things i
had fought for a long time before
they come from very simple
circumstances i come from
nowhere i already had everything there was
no commercial reason for me to do it
to sell that was i
wanted to change my life and i also
wanted this third of my life the
second third of my life i wanted
somehow  how cool cool end so not
that you also live for but
but this what i my first life
third that was stuntman wild free danger
and everything young men just to do
and like sound in life
then someday you will be a father and the
second third of life begins  and things
change and you take responsibility
and suddenly you have built up a large company
, you are responsible for
hundreds of employees and then you are just an
entrepreneur and of course I
still went skydiving behind them
and drove
the basement and love the loneliness of the north with
a sea kayak so i have  yes i do
n't punish myself excessively
sometimes but then there has to come a
point where something like this happens now
and the concept was what
had been agreed with thomas ebeling that we would
then merge the jochen schweizer erlebnis portal
with the mydays we bought five years ago
to  jochen schweizer my
disco and he asked me if
i  ch a part of my ex redeemer small
part only a few million it sounds like a
lot and may sound arrogant but against
the
background it is i don't mean it like that
anyway i have invested in
switzerland the scope and
and accompanies the company
to where it actually is  it's
part of becoming a unicorn and that
's possible because we're doing that the next
units in the next few months yes where
is a process i
don't run this company i would
probably be a bit braver but
now we're integrated into the group
with the company and there are different
framework conditions
what is the difference is i have never played
on the portals report but
if you as a founder entrepreneur as
owner prince company then it is
important to you that the company is
cleanly positioned in the long term
that the people in the company are doing well
and it is the balance sheet result for the
coming  year much less important
than the balance sheet result in  five years
the group, above all a
listed group, is
driven by quarterly reports and in
my opinion that sometimes hinders
everyone in certain
companies to really develop optimally with all the
given potential
that doesn’t mean that
things are going badly according to how long
they need now  i do
n't know but i accompanied it as best i can
people already heard it i put on
my ready voice today so it's still a
bit brittle but that's exactly where it helps anyway
ready the as bacteria are proven for
hoarseness and coughing and are
very popular with people in  agree
active professions like mine use here
so the apparatus is good for the throat and not
just the throat but you also do
something good if you consume the pallas
because behind it is the dr pfleger
arzneimittel gmbh which belongs 100% to a
foundation and all profiles the
funds  ready to be made for example
exclusively for charity  ive purposes
i.e. for kindergartens
schools for basic medical research
by the way there is something new from parat
namely palaver twelve new
flavors of ingredients such as telephone and vitamin c these new
devices are also available in selected
pharmacies in 100 percent
sustainable packaging who might
even be funny now  working for dr
pfleger Fahrrad currently
looking for a board manager a brand manager who wants to help
the community grow
who would want to control marketing and
who, as a special bonus, would of course work closely
with doctors because we
are also partners there short application to
info  at the pit.de
[music]
have how much money he still has a company
how much percent 10 percent is okay
that's already relevant for you
so if this should really become a
unicorn then it would be
almost as much or even more
you got more than the change,
but I don't think that's the way it is  ht
that's not the point point is
i always put protection of
the brand
before protection of the eta it was
always more important that we don't do
anything that damages the brand but
maybe drives profits but always the
other way around i always said the
brand is  holy jochen schweizer is
a brand how is credible is
authentic and i just want to be
truthful with this man is
the company has grown a lot now in the
last one so be a merger power yes they
are now under swiss the former
archenemies now together how big is
the company  we weren't
sworn enemies we just screwed them up
where we showed them
but it's gotten big now
it's already worked that said now,
so to speak, mostly the fans
doubled in size or how do
you have to imagine that so
I won't give out any business figures that
's true too  the articles of incorporation alone do not prohibit my task as a
partner  n but of
course all of our businesses
have been affected by corona
, regardless of which the
company is developing very favorably
and i am optimistic
about the future, but my life today
is such that we have recognized over time at
jochen schweizer okay
there are certain  experience this one in
particular and they are also a
lot of fun themselves and they work well and
then you need this
arena from it and it fulfills it so it
tells a bit about everything that is
offered that means you are now
mainly focused next to your
speaker activities and  author
activities as an entrepreneur one of a
large property of a venue i imagine
that where people then flock
to cologne to enjoy all kinds of experiences
because above all you
lead and that’s nice the
arena is built for
emotional company events
so for the live events in the meantime I
also have e  in the streaming studio and stream a
lot of events but that's corona
driven of course we were in lockdown for nine months
but maybe I have
to go into more detail what
entrepreneurs were doing when a
group executive board explained we've now
bought the smaller competitor and
now we're going to flatten you  then
you think about it wow that's an
announcement for infinitely more money you
have the media coverage you don't
have you have the air sovereignty what are
you doing now and our counter strategy
was then that on the one hand we used my
person as a brand icon
that was then  already a strategy to give this
a natural credibility to the
company second
we have life opened jochen schweizer
shops three pieces customs officers yes in highly
frequented shopping malls an average of
30,000 people walk
past it every day that also has
communication value and natural are
these
shops are our trust and  our most
expensive sales channel but it is a
profitable sales channel in
truth the shops are subscription marketing instrument
is a marketing instrument that
i paid for myself
the others somehow
our idea was simply better and the
third topic was of course that we
all looked for ways and means of how
can we
generate credibility in generic traffic and then we said
, funny
enough, that's what we decided back then when meides was bought and
this statement came, we sat
in my old hut in norway
we do that once a year with my top
people just sits in mine  old hut
drinking a beer had been fishing
laying the mackerel on the grill and then
we decided
we drank more beer and
by the time morning came we had
decided we'd build a gnawing house now
we'd decided 23 10 and
we want the brand house everything  pack in
what we check it
means 300 people a day  walk in there
you said how many more
300,000 daily visitors per year and before
krone we had three 100 company
events per year ok ok ok
then corona
kicked it out ok ok they say but
you are back now then these
300,000 of you then  back to
work on this we survived and
we're starting to breathe
again but that's to say then the main job
that there that that's what you're doing now that
my main job and writing books and
then we'll counter that to be honest we
'll talk even before that
writing books because that's a
lot of fun for me and then let's
say goodbye
so I have to explain with a myth
what's happening right now as well as formative
for you was the time at the hut
lion and that's what
all the years of the brand have brought about  to charge that
the broker was of course a strong
advantage why it was then but out of the
show more for those same reasons
there  ss i was part of this
fantastic show after three years and also helped shape
celia and then this path came
to an end for me because
you know at some point you start
to take yourself really seriously when you
get so many people and you
should avoid that me  I don't
want to lose my grip on reality and you are a
television investor I like to invest in companies
outside of television where
I then have an incredible amount of time
to deal with the founders and with
the business plans and with the
market you can't do that as a
lion in the  cave that he's incredibly
difficult as a lion because in fractions the
pritz lasts an hour and a half it's
cut down to 20 minutes afterwards
in post production and you have to make
a decision in an hour and a half
hey ok watch out I'll give you 200k 14
percent
and then you won't have it  license and
maybe you don't learn everything that
you should be told from the founder
g  What a surprise was said
and they try to somehow save the deal
because of course they are also under
such social pressure that this
handshake should also apply you want
it to apply but sometimes
things go unmentioned that
would have been better mentioned and then I
might not have  invested
of course i made a few investments in the lion's den they fell flat
and i made
them went really well what was better
for the porridge for example
before everly i invested 150 thousand
in a wedding
because we  the founder was so sorry she
didn't have her back to the wall and
i thought to myself well until
convincing there are many weddings the
more divorces and then there are
new weddings again
and they all have to be organized so
you can get money different that was  so
funny after the patch the box gets
up and tells me the
150000 right now  t can show next to
you
and he was unfortunately right okay but
then the two bumblebees arrived so the
two founders gave tips who were then
already killed by the new business models that will never
work and
I said to them guys you’re
like it’s only two bumblebees  yes, if the
bumblebee has a body weight of 0.7 grams
and a wing area of 1.2 squar
centimeters and according to all the laws
f aerodynamics known to us, you can't
lay it, but you don't know it and y
u just do it twice
with your business model
actually no chance at all but
somehow i invest these 150000 now
and then i got money back
20 times ok
or i have but my best investment
was then outside the cave of the lions
regiondo region through software house
i invested a million software as
service
and the region alone so the whole
vw autostadt runs on regions for example
this resource  In management
systems, experience providers
or any form of operation can
manage their own resources via
regiondo
and thus get a large
additional range, but at the same
time sales surfaces such as
experience gifts portal and others
can access them nationwide and market these
resources
that are managed by the system
and this is a company on its own has
the potential to go in the direction that is initially
skewed one day
so in june you
could do that i don't know exactly but in any
case the company has huge potential
and has invested its value many times at an early stage
have
okay okay but it's on  in the end you
marketed despite these bumblebees what did
they do what should they have they
have separated and re-finding trips and special trips
that is actually a lot of
freaks two young travel agents
we had no incoming
agent system at all i have of course  lich
invested with a certain reason because
they have the worldwide experience partner
and thought to me that
we can solve the problem at the end of
the day to get out of the lion's den rich in
experience rich in encounters
and maybe with that halfway
with a halfway okay  return of
investment so we're talking about what
suzuki is over the years to the 6 million
invested so maybe i didn't
i always provided a million per episode
but was never able to
invest the whole million because there
simply weren't enough cases where i
said that  is it okay now that
means but i can say i can say
i got my money back
maybe with a real interest rate
of 15 percent or so and and 20 or
20 percent confirmed but a lot of
work behind it so you would have that
is still a  for a while
you would have bought real estate in munich with the money
you would definitely be
further ahead kom  hey, but
that's what it was about for me, of course, yes, i
wanted to help the founder
and also and it was fun
for me too,
i thought the format was good and the
competition with the lion was of
course not without a need before
should or there  there
is still permanent damage or
do you have good houses with all of them
not at all well i have i am
first of all i personally am not a vindictive person at all
i can
work things out with someone but then
it's okay again  well other people
may be different but have to be able to
deal with it myself i can that's
not my problem and with some
lions the new contact with others
i don't want to judge that at all
means that we are no different with you
yes you meet hundreds of  people
and hate in the five friends and stuff like that
still happens today so if you think about it
now you've
got a bit of
structure in your life  rt now
what do you have the arena
do you still have goals or well yes of course
there are many but other many
look i just wrote a
novel in my old hut in norway
that is an anecdote they
can tell you  it's really like i
've had the experience that
some successes in life result from
defeats
and when the novel came out
i was recently at the book fair in
vienna and that means this orf book
expert is there in his chair on the
stage and you have a  auditorium down there
in 1000 seats and depending on the
interest in the book whose visitors are
seated in the respective author
between 50 and 1000 people with miss
rabbits there maybe 200 there is
a very realistic picture of
yourself this fat guy is sitting there
with you  literature expert in his chair across from
me and there
we go like this jochen swiss
blablabla stuntman unfortunately bored the usual
I've
written a little book in the meantime his third book
his last his second book was also
a bestseller were non-fiction
but
then i'm swiss myself
so you're a novelist now
it just turned out to be a key novel
and i've already started to be so
happy  cool
cooler is looking forward to june thanks the
next sentence you wo
n't be successful with this book i
thought to myself ok alright
now it's going in the other direction he
says if you like this novel has a
depth and a spirituality that you
wouldn't think you are capable of  which is also
diametrically opposed to your public
brand image, i.e. the one who wants
adrenaline, i hit it underneath, etc., but
also explains it in detail and
i got a real
kick out of it
and then actually didn’t
write a great book as said
, but you won’t be
successful  the
quintessence and then I didn't even get an invitation to
the talk shows  l
normally you are through the
talk shows and advertise your
book that didn’t work out at all
i don’t have a tail it was a
fact that
i met my novel with the
credit a story about the way
to a self-determined life
maybe not immediately triggered by the
media yes  especially insider writes with
my name and no interest i
thought to myself damn damn damn
what am i doing now now i
always had a lot of influenza coming and content
creators in my arena who
staged themselves there
and now i know 10 of them  15
boys and girls yes they then have a
technical range of no
idea 20 million lost
the phone set whether they
called one after the other well i
really have a topic no tail is
interested in my book i need but
now somehow i need range
otherwise otherwise i can manage  there is no way
that the book will be a success because
they all posted  I
sent him the book some
actually read it others
just posted it out of kindness
jochen wrote a cool book people have a
look could buy it now from
thalia de and so on or in
bookstores
we concentrated
that, so to speak, these publications
we massaged for a period of
two weeks
are you making yourself plate suspect
obtain mirror bestseller
one week later number
one bestseller themes bestseller
spirituality
i think it's worth remembering how awesome
added olot i think got a very
good feeling who you are like you
before  you can also see how things were partly
planned and
forced but also partly
happened and somehow came about
for you many many thanks
for the insights and promises for the jochen schweizer update
then give that you thought of yourself you
there  is also soon
when bassam sleeps then he sleeps
because of some noise  didn't wake up for a long
time i was also sleeping where exactly
next to our family house
noticed
because it was very funny so bad but
very funny situation i didn't
wake up
the true story of a
young syrian fleeing the civil war
in his  home
everything that has to do with violence or
tried in syria across the mediterranean
sea where it was very bad for that
what was the worst thing i really
experienced until a new life in
germany
what now hear his story
everywhere where there is a podcast
this podcast will be  produced by
popstars
at mr